A signal processing hook.
So I designed my train.
Sorry. Actually, I just one thing change.
Could you just restart that
but go for it. OK.
Thanks for the introduction, Dan.
My name is Fritz.
I'm a professor in Beethoven
and Beethoven.
University of Technology
in the Netherlands.
I'd be a part of
an electrical engineering department
in the signal processing group.
So we design
signal processing algorithms.
And about six, seven years ago,
I read the first time
a paperback health system
was called A Rough Guide to the Brain.
And it struck me that
this could be fantastic for processing.
So since then, I'm really trying
to work with people in my lab,
realizing, realizing agents
that are still designed to automate
the design process of a signal processing
algorithms
are simply doing it by mass passing.
And we want to talk about it today.
Thanks.
Yeah.
My name is Jason Love,
and those stick with Birth Lab.
I did my best deal.
So an active inference
and how to automate those processes.
And also together with my books
and all the colleagues from the lab,
we built a tool box lab
and I'll be talking and we'll can you to
how we apply that
in an active interest of infants contacts
and do some cool things with it.
And so that's for later oh
yeah. Hello, everyone.
So my name is Nick Tebogo.
I'm a teacher, candidate and bias lab
also in t in the university.
And my work is mostly about reactive,
moisturizing based Bayesian inference
that we hope will help
effective imprints as well.
But that's also for later.
I will talk about that on my time. Unless
cool.
Thank you.
OK, sure.
Shall I go down and do a little
introduction, a few slides?
Privacy.
Yeah. OK,
let's see if I can share my slides.
Yep. Looks good.
Yeah. OK.
So the first slide is
I don't because you may wonder where
I am in relation to Amsterdam.
Well, it's about a hundred kilometers
south of Amsterdam,
close to the Belgium border
and also so far away from Germany there.
So it's, it's sort of a high tech city.
Philips
is getting to the right,
but you see a picture of the center
and the right top is a view of the campus
of the University of Technology.
Here's an aerial view approach.
So it's inside.
Here's an aerial view of
our campus.
And so here let's see
if I can share pointer.
Yeah.
So this is the building
for electrical engineering.
So this is where we are I is lab is short
for Bayesian intelligence.
It's all in the systems.
That's what we try to
build and we have about three
staff members,
faculty members
and currently 60 students.
Dimitry is one of those busy students
and we have open positions.
If there are people watching
that are interested in probabilistic
programing
or how to make activations work,
fine, but we're trying to do it.
This is a picture that's
probably familiar to everybody in this
room, right?
This is our chance to show that.
Well, the only thing that's
really going on in the brain is strategy
minimization or expected
fairness minimization to do everything
and that's a huge inspiration to us
as engineers.
So what we trying to do is basically this
we want to put this in an iPhone
or an IRS prepaid and let the robot learn
how to ride a bike.
But the beauty of this framework
for engineering purposes
is that it's almost one
solution approach to any problem.
So if we can do it, if you teach a robot
how to ride a bike
by free energy minimization,
probably we can also apply this
in virtual reality to design algorithms.
So having kids or even self-driving cars,
the the
big let's
say promise or the attractiveness
for engineering is that it is just one
always the same thing.
You just have to approach a model
and minimization is you,
no matter what the application is.
That's very appealing.
The problem for engineering is
that this energy functional
is a function of observations
and observations.
Streaming data coming usually.
Well, could be at every millisecond.
So it's a highly time varying function.
And the number of latent variables
that say
that the space of late
the variables is usually very high.
So we have a very high dimensional
function that is time value and
we want to minimize that.
Now, the brain is very good at it, right?
The brain has just ten to 14
sign ups and a billion neurons
but in normal
optimization library
and MATLAB will not cut that.
You cannot minimize
a time varying function
of how it has variables
in that stuff can work.
So we need something quite radical here.
And the idea we go
with is not that radical.
Again, we just take inspiration
from the brain, right?
The brain is a network of message passing
and it turns out in my own field
in signal processing
or information theory to be exact,
this has been formalized
paper here by day for me in
2001 coaching graphs and realizations.
He call it normal
sector graphs in honor of the fit
for me today
difficult for me still active maps
and so this is the origin of the factor
graphs
that we are talking about
and a few years later
concentrating a little year
at a university in the series
I have made this
popular in the signal
processing community
and already around 2007
you see in in his papers these
these typical structures like this
that we will show also later
these are common filters
and this is really also a twist that
talks about these kinds of structures.
So this is what we want to do
in our lab is just to combine what
active inference
from the inspire inspiration
from the neuroscience community
and combine it with what we know
is signal processing and information
theory about spectrographs
and use these tools to to implement this
so today we have two presentations
one test on the layer
on how to do mass passing back
44 new lab is the tool box that we wrote
on the main
of course your first two did finally
and thanks for sure
how to do executions with this tool box.
Now we're
also working on a new version is called
reactive mouse dispatching through
Dimitri is the main person there
Dimitri also I'll talk about that a bit
and that's all for me
I'll get it back to you then
or maybe you can continue.
What is your preference?
So stop sharing my screen.
See it's super interesting.
Thanks a lot for the context and
it will be awesome
to hear from the authors
with maybe any reflections
on those general points you raised
and how it gets applied
in a really specific way
because you brought up a ton of topics
that we talk about all the time, like
the simplicity of one unified approach
and the challenges
of ongoing optimization problems
and drawing inspiration from nature.
So great things.
I think we can just jump to whichever
of the presentation you all prefer.
All right, then
I'll go ahead and try to show my screen,
see if that works.
So back to our screen and the screen. OK.
Fractal screen.
So you can see my screen now. Yep.
And you can make it look just large
on your side and I'll resize it there.
We go. Looks great.
Now. Yeah.
All right.
Well, thanks again for having us.
Can you take away.
The beginning little introduction? Sorry.
Where it says you're sharing your screen.
You can tie that little gypsy thing.
And it's gone.
Thank you.
So, yeah, I'll be giving
a little introduction
on how to do a message fussing
with in the context of active inference.
And to give a little bit of motivation
for this talk.
And this is kind of a situation
where we're interested in.
So we have some kind of an environment
and we have an assignment.
The process is running
in the environment,
and we want to develop an agent
that has some purpose
or does some purposeful
task within that environment.
And the agent is allowed to
send actions to the environment
and manipulate that environment.
And it will receive observations
and in the environment
process, there is some function already
that is running there,
and it might be simulation
that we run, that we interact with that
or it might be used in a real world
process, of which of course
we don't really know
what it is running into real world.
And somehow we want to build an agent
that does something in that world.
So where do you start with that
there's this paper
from going into SD in the 1970s
and they have an interesting theorem
that says that
every good regulator of a system
must be a model of the system.
So that actually means that
if you want to build an agent
that regulates or manipulates our system,
the environment,
then we have to model that system.
So as an engineer we
are in the business of building models,
generative models, to be precise.
And this model represents our beliefs
about how observations
follow from our manipulations.
We were presented by a function
F that is a function of Y.
The observations
the controls you
and also some latent state
hidden variables X
and that act as an intermediate
between observations
that controls
now reasoning forward is one thing,
but in the end
what we want to do is observe things
and then propose controls
that lead us to favorable states.
And that is where the idea
of the free energy
principle and active inference comes in.
So if we want to say
this is the hypothesis for that,
if you want to build an agent
that does something purposeful,
then we can do that by minimizing
if we are bound on surprise.
So we want
to build an agent to avoid surprises,
and by that we can do Bayesian inferences
about that environment.
So we have to build
some kind of energy functional
for the agent to optimize.
And by that we do Bayesian inferences
for actions and controls
and we defined
is for energy functional
as a scale divergence
between the generative model that we have
and some kind of an approximate posterior
that we postulate.
And we here define beauty
and minimizing
this energy functional will
then allow us to reason backwards
from observations
towards controls
and this kind of the general idea.
And having postulated
this, I have two choices to make.
So for example, one big choice
that I want to make is
how do I choose my model?
How do I choose my F in
such a way that is useful to me?
And also how do I choose my Q to do it?
Choose the fact resolution of this
and such that
I can make my inferences
and that process
is kind of a thing of trial and error.
And as an engineer, I want,
of course to build the best model
that I possibly can.
But how go how do I go as quickly
as possible through a process of trial
and error that gives me the best,
most the best model
and this is where the idea
of the model design cycle comes in.
And this was again
made popular by David Blight
in his paper in 2000 to 14 builds
compute quickly repeat
and he proposes this cycle
where an engineer proposes a model
and then with that model
you want to infer your quantities
of interest given data
and if you have some sort of model
that you want to criticize it
and and based upon, well the performance
that you have evaluated,
you want to reiterate rebuild your model,
infer again and see how well it
then performs until you're satisfied
and you can apply it in your agent and
in practice maybe in a real world setting
and then the challenge becomes
then how do I go through this
design cycle as quickly as possible?
So we want to be flexible,
we want to automate things.
And making model proposals itself
is something that you have to do
as an as an engineer.
You have to come up with a proposal
of how you believe the world functions.
But once you have that,
everything else can be automated
you can infer as
quantities by probabilistic programing.
You can evaluate free energy as a measure
of model performance
and automating this cycle will be the key
to making model proposals for an agent
that will be useful in practice.
So you want to go through this
as quickly as possible.
So that's why
we choose a specific message.
We choose effective routes
to represent our federalized models
because in a graph
you can do manipulations,
you can add nodes, delete nodes,
you can rewire things very quickly.
And once you have a graph
going up an addition of your model,
you can do a message passing on that
graph in order to automate inference.
And you can even evaluate free energy
by local contributions in that graph.
So that's why
we choose a graphical representation, and
that is why we want to do message plus
because we want to design models quickly
so that we can design effective agents
now how do these graphs
kind of work, right?
How do you build an effective graph
and what does that look like?
So it uses specific
representation of our model.
And this is an example where we have
generative model of five variables
x one, two x five
and we have three factors
A, B and C,
and here in the picture on the right
is the graphical representation
of that model and as you can see,
the edges corresponds to the variables
and the nodes correspond to the factors
and the edges are connected
to the nodes
of which the factors are an argument.
So here you see node as a with connect.
So just sort of next to
that is because excellent
next to our arguments as a say as B and C
so how do we do inference in this graph?
So suppose that we observe X fight
which is indicated
by this little solid square
and we want to compute our belief over x
still given x five.
Well, what do you do?
Well, you marginal everything.
And by marginalization
I mean you integrate out every variable
except the one that you're interested in.
So except x two,
you integrate everything out
and you add this constraint.
If you observe X fights
now if you had a big model
done, this integration becomes
very cumbersome because this here is
you have to have four variables
of which to integrate.
So this room, this,
this integration space,
if that really explodes,
if you want to do it, is now easily
which you can be smart about this.
You can
you can
re shuffle
these integrals
according to their respective terms.
So for example,
this integration over x five.
Well there is only one factor
where x five is an argument us.
So I can use distributive rules
to bring this integral inside
so that I divide these integrals
up into smaller parts
which are manageable
and this is where message
palsson comes from.
Message passing is essentially solving
these integrations one by one
so we can first integrate, integrate out
x x one here, for example,
which as we say, summarizes
all the information inside this orange
box that gives us message,
first message here
that exits this orange box
and then it can continue for the bottom.
So integrate, integrate out
X phase and I get a second message
and I can use
this second message
in the computation of the third message.
So this way
you get a nested solution approach
where I use the solution
that you have for message
two in the computation for message three
and you see that in the end,
the multiplication of these
two colliding messages on the edge for X
two will give me
my proportional belief
my proportional posterior
over X two, given what I have observed
so to give a little example
of the specific note how that works,
here's inequality
constraint note which we use
as as a constraint to
the constraint beliefs upon the adjacent
edges to be equal
and what that does is
it will follow
if we if we go through the math here
that I'm this is what the note function
looks like.
So I say, OK, is function
three variables X, Y and Z,
and I constrain Z to be X and I constrain
Z also to be Y.
So then X will also be Y
if a constraint should be the same.
So let's see if we can derive
messages based upon this
so if I want to summarize
the information into this orange box,
I can use the same product rule.
For that.
I have to do messages coming in here
from the left and from the bottom.
Message one and message two.
I multiply that
by the note function of the equality node
and I want to perform this integration
now a substitute.
This is this node function here
with integration.
Then I can use the system property
to kind of replace
the arguments here of X
and Y with the argument.
So Z.
So what I have essentially done here
is saying I can compute this message
three by multiplying
the two messages that are incoming from
the left and from the bottom
Now, if you
squint your eyes a bit and you look,
you look through your eyes,
you can kind of recognize
the proportional Bayes rule in here.
So essentially you can say, well,
if message three here
represents my posterior,
the message one can represent
my prior message to my likelihood
and then I have a proportional
to Syria message three
and that I can pass on
to the rest of my model.
And this note is also often
used to kind of combine information
that's coming from the lesson
from the bottom
and so this is very quick introduction
to do message passing.
We have derived lots of rules
also from the literature also implemented
a lot of rules that already derives
into into 48, which is basically
well software
for all this programing suites that
does the
scheduling
and does message computation for you.
So you don't have to think about that
too much.
How to redistribute these integrals
and how to derive
a lot of updates for specific notes
so that's kind of
the things that that we can,
we can automate
on that side of the of the design cycle
now are there any questions about this
because I'm going to this very quickly
and what I'm going to do next is kind of
want to walk through an example
so maybe this is kind of a natural point
where people have questions
that they can kind of stop me and say,
OK, how are you going to first here.
I think it'll be good to see the example.
And then we have some questions
in the live chat
and also anyone's welcome to have more.
All right. So
so how do you do this in practice
in an active inference context?
So this is a little example.
It's called Basement Thermostat.
Where we have
an environment of environment.
So where we have a heat source
here on the left and we have a little car
that can move around,
it can move away from the heat source
or it can move towards the heat source.
Now, to position
relative to the heat
source is what we call X.
And at every position
there is a specific temperature
and temperature that we measure
in a specific position
is what we call white
and we have a preference
of being at a temperature of four
Y for, I don't know, something we choose
so we can control this car
by moving in left or right.
And our control is the velocity that we
move left or right with and schools, you
so this is our environments
and we want to build a model for that.
So it actually prints
what we want to do is
we want to reason
from space where we would like to be
towards controls
that we have to apply at this current
of this current time
in order to get there in the future.
So what we want to do is we want to
reason forward from the current time.
20 up until some time horizon victim.
And in the future
we want to consider
how the agent will move
and where we want
that agent to be at that time.
And in the end
we will want to be
at a temperature of four
and at the space based model that
represents our belief for how this agent
will will
move itself through the world
so at time t we have an observation
coming in of a specific temperature
and maybe we have already made an action
and we see that
the current state actually relates
to the previous state and action
that we have by by adding
so basically you see here is velocity
that we add to a current position
in one time step.
And then we get kind of our next position
by just adding that
and also applying some caution noise.
So we have a state transition
that is the of this
with a duty saying
I want to move forward to the left or 42.
Right,
and then we add some noise saying,
OK, we're kind of uncertain about
how this agent might move
in the environments.
We have an idea about that,
but let's add some variance in order
to account for some uncertainties
and then
we say here what this vertical line is,
if we have
an observation or if we have a position
and it relates to an observation
of the temperature by well -1,
it's kind of a rough guess.
It's just saying, well,
if I move to the right,
if I move away from my heat source,
then my temperature will decline
with a slope of -1.
And it's kind of a really rough
guess in the real world.
There will be a very nice temperature
gradient that maybe will move but
will move very slowly downwards.
But we're just saying, hey,
we don't really know what that is.
Let's make a rough guess.
We have a belief this is our generative
model, our beliefs about the world.
Let's just say
that temperature decreases with position
and again,
we're not very certain about that.
So let's again
ADD and some Gaussian noise
and now extend this into the future.
So I say actually
I believe that in the future
my will also evolve according to this
but I also have
some ideas about where I want to be.
And this is where a goal prior is coming
that constrain my future
observations of the temperature
to be around
this desired temperature of four.
And I'm saying
then here with some added noise well,
I want to be around for my
it doesn't have to be exactly,
but I want to be pretty certain that
I will be around four at times
plus one and I will continue
to remain there
until sometime in the future.
You now over generative model
and we can define of energy functional
and we can solve this for energy
functional by message
passing on this graph and we pass
these messages towards our next control
because we're interested in inferring
what we have to do next like front from
so next time
and this is where we can do
message passing,
we can summarize all the information
that we have from, from the past.
So this will be an estimate
of the current state of the agent
and it will be biased by our beliefs
about the future and seeing
where we want to be.
And that will influence or determine
which control that we will take
at the present time or the next slide
or the details of this are
described
in this paper from two dozen in 19
by Berton me
and there
you can also see again how we applied it
within the actually perceptual look
the things like that
because you will have to do this
at every time
because your state estimate will change
or words
will change according to your actions.
So you will for every time you will have
to recapture a new action for what
you're going to do next
and this is kind of the the main idea.
Now, of course, we don't want to do
everything of this by hand.
So what we want to do is, well,
we want to use a tool for that
so now I'm going to show a little demo
of how you would implement this
using the different
probabilistic program tool
so let's see if I can
open a little demo.
So this is
this is readable, actually,
or should I assume in more.
You can zoom in a little bit more.
Maybe like this.
Yeah, I can resize it.
Yeah.
That that's pretty good.
Oh, that's perfect.
That's pretty good. Yep.
Thank you.
Let's
so this is so so it's kind of
an what what we want to do
but so this is kind of our definition
of the environment itself.
So this is the real world where we have
this, this temperature gradient,
which is a very nice function
so a very smooth function.
What a heat source we have temperature
of 100 and it,
it goes down with that
with which position from that heat source
so this is a real world.
We don't really know this.
So this is the one that we're going
to approximate with this
very rough -1
and then we'll see whether it will work.
Right now this is my wonderful ASCII art.
It has now been resized
of basically the model that I've just
shown in slides
and this here is a model definition.
So actually I have to zoom out a bit
to make it more readable.
Yeah.
So we want to build a graph
for this, right?
So here we have our observation
states controls
and we define a prior belief
about T -1.
So where have we been?
Which we going to say is Goshen.
And with some mean and some variance
and then for every time into the future
from, from one into the horizon
and we
will have probably four border controls
which basically says, well,
what am I allowed to do?
And I say, OK, well,
I have I have got prior
bad controls with what I mean, zero,
I'll substitute that here
and then maybe some variance
and here I say, well,
I have my position of the agent
which relates to my controls
by just this addition
with some decision domain.
So this is a transition model
is this horizontal
line,
and this is an observation model
which is very
rough estimate -1 temperature
gradient times
current state
and also some some some precision
conservation precision.
And this represents my goal prior.
So note that I haven't really
put in any specific values here yet.
I just have placeholders
for actual statistics and values that I'm
going to put in
because the
actual derivation of my algorithm,
it doesn't really depend upon statistics.
It's just something that we can
we can put in later
so this is what I want to do better
for energy functional.
And it's funny,
like there's actually just basically
four lines of code
so posterior factorization
that defines my factorization
for Q saying that
I'm just going to
has a joints for internal distribution.
So over the entire graph,
I don't really subdivided into structure
and into a structured factorization.
Some people are familiar with that,
but I just say,
OK, I'll just have this posterior
sexualization situation distribution
to be distributions graphs
and then never just one command.
I can derive message passing algorithm
that propagates all the messages
towards control as you do with which
which is the control for the next time.
Step two plus one
and I want to evaluate my fan.
So also gives me at the same time
an algorithm that I can,
I can execute
in order to accelerate my free energy
and this line
will convert this to the source code.
And then I can
then load in my environment
and what this does is
it builds the message
passing algorithm for us.
So this is this this is the code
that executes the message passing
on our growth.
And here you can see there is computes
all these messages by some product rules
and other rules that we have pre derived
and we have implemented in format.
And you can see that these messages,
they depend upon the statistics.
So this is for example,
the means of of a prior
overstates
and variance of a prior overstates
and we have a lot of
messages
that depend upon previous messages
and the way that I explain
message passing
and this built an entire list of
well in this case 26 messages
and in the end we're interested
in the marginal beliefs.
So it is still your marginal beliefs
about about for example our controls
and you get these beliefs
on multiplying messages together.
So for example,
to get a new belief over control
you multiply messages nine and 25
and you also recognize this
from little introduction, introduction,
the colliding messages
that you multiply in order
to get your posterior release.
And that's what we return to
and that's what we're interested in.
So this is an execution
of that algorithm.
And notice
that we've made an entire schedule here
and that can be very cumbersome.
It can be very long, very long schedule.
So that makes it expensive
maybe to load and execute.
And Demetrius, the
solution for that
and we'll explain that in a minute.
So I'm very happy about billing schedules
and imagery, not so much
he tries to find a solution
for get rid of them
because in the end there will be two plus
two really don't have a schedule
that really had recipe, but just goodbye.
Whatever is given to you
so now we execute
this algorithm in practice.
So this is our action perception loop
for every time step.
We want to
we want to actually once
we have a connection for the agents,
we want to execute that.
That's the action
in the, in the, in the environment.
So this is sending the action towards
the actual real world
or kind of simulated world in this case.
And what we get
from that is an observation
and from our
action observation, we want to infer
onset of our new action and also return
the variation of the energy
and then prepare for the next step.
So in every step
we propose an action to the environment.
Action gets executed, we observe
new outcome, we infer a new action,
and we evaluate how well we did
with that action.
And then you get a nice plus like this.
So this is the velocity of our agents.
We start at zero and you can see that
it moves very quickly to the right
and then
it also moves back a little bit
until the end comes
to a stationary point,
more or less
and you can see actually here
what it does.
So it starts out with a temperature of 20
and then it moves very quickly
to the rights away from the heat
source it overshoots its mark
and then it
actually goes back and then settles
around its desired temperature.
For that we have encode is by by our goal
priors. OK,
so why this overshoot?
Well, our model of the environment
wasn't perfect, right?
We had this very rough
estimate of minus -1
and the real world.
This is very nice,
smooth, kind of complicated function.
And there is this kind of bell shape
so even though
our generative model of the environment
wasn't perfect
and in the end we provided before that
by shooting a little bit, but still
we were able to get to our desired state
at a temperature of four.
So in the end,
it kind of worked pretty well
and you can also see that
the free energy of the agent
also decreases with time.
So we start off at around a thousand.
So the skills logarithmic here
and it decreases very quickly
to some value and it's rather rather low.
And then we have some noise
that induces some
unexpected changes
or some unexpected surprise.
So that's
why you have these little ripples,
these little ripples here.
But in the entry minimizing for energy
and it's going to suppress.
OK, so we actually have this free energy
minimizing agent
and yeah, that's
that's basically
all I have the story and,
and the demo
was awesome.
Thank you very much.
We can with screen share on or not ask
a few of the questions from the live chat
and also give people a few seconds
to type more.
So I'm just going to jump
into the questions.
First quote, let me stock my screen here.
Great. So, so sharing the screen so.
We see just the jitsu.
So just click the screen
share button again and should see OK.
So awesome.
Thank you. So the first question
is from John and John writes,
how does the factor graph approach work
if the graph structure is not known
beforehand,
is structure learning possible
how yeah.
So so that's a good question.
So is structure learning
possible in graphs like these
so that is actually
something that is still
an active field of research.
That would be awesome.
If you can automate also the structure
learning of the graph itself,
but there are a lot of challenges there.
So how do you parameterize
this graph structure
and how do you do
how do you do that actually?
Right.
What is your search space
in terms of graphs?
How do you
how do you learn node functions
if you don't have a node function
given for your graphs?
Right.
So these are all very difficult questions
and you don't have
a straightforward answer.
So so that's why
this actual model design
steps in the design secret cycle itself.
Is still kind of a creative process.
There is an engineer
that has to come up with a model.
And as an engineer, you also have to
think about how to adjust that model.
If you're not satisfied with it.
So if energy is still high,
also you run your agents
well, something is going on
or something is wrong with your model.
It's not an accurate representation
of what is the environment.
And then you might adjust that.
How do you adjust it?
But currently
it's still just trial and error.
So maybe you can say, OK,
I think here is still something
that I can improve, maybe remove a node,
maybe model's too complex and
the structure wrong in itself is
it is something that is also
it can be addressed.
So there are methods like, like nested
model comparison and things like that
that you can do in fact growth.
So you can for example, if you have
this model compute service decorates
you and then kind of prune
your model based upon that.
And so those are things that you can do
to find a complex model
and see what you can cut away
but adding to
that model is still difficult.
So once you've got an array, well,
how do you add add?
I don't I don't really know.
So it's a good question and I do
that is very straightforward
and which you can do for my rattling.
So yeah,
perhaps I can say something about me.
I mean, I totally agree with with ties.
I mean, generally when you design
a system or a signal processing system,
you have to design the structure,
you have to estimate the parameters,
and then you have to infer states
and states change very fast,
at least the common filter.
And that's very well known.
In fact, the graphs then the next stage
would be can be also over the long
term, learn the parameters and oh effect
the graphs can do that pretty well.
Now, the next stage in biology,
I mean we know who the structure is
also over even longer time. So
and so that's not working at the moment
in life you can compare like tests.
I says if you have two examples,
you can compare the energy
and just pick the best one.
But we are
working on that and we will take it again
to lead by Tom McConnell's idea
on Bayesian model reduction.
But how to implement that in effect?
The graph is a research project
so we're working on that
and I'm not sure where it will end,
but that's our goal
that you have basically
a position available.
So also to bring it back
to the example of the motor car
getting to an optimal temperature,
it's like if every hour you notice
that there was a bump in the free energy,
then you go back to the drawing board
and you go to the
people who are on that car in that area
and ask, Well, what happens every hour?
Or maybe we do need to include
this other source of information.
But the model that you had does its job,
so you could include the wallpaper
and other features of the room.
But that's kind of this
art and science of engineering.
And that's
why it's always interesting to work
because often in research
it's like, let's finish the analysis
but really there's this cycle that
the entire model is embedded within
that helps us always keep an eye out
for those patterns that are precluding
being captured by our current models.
Here's a story.
Well.
Here's a second question from the chat.
How does the Factor graph approach work
if the goal temperature in this example
is not defined beforehand,
can the goal be abstract?
So kind of a similar question,
but rather than structure learning,
how does preference and goal orientation
arise
again?
Excellent question.
So that kind of leads to the question,
well, who sets the goals
or how did you set goals
so yeah,
the plain answer to that is, well,
it's an engineer that defines that,
but it can also be higher level agents
that does influence and sets those goals
so then you get to kind of turtles
all the way down arguments
in the sense, well, you can put layer
upon layer upon layer of layer
layers to goals and other as goals
for that layer, et cetera, et cetera.
So how do how that will work in practice?
Yeah, that's still again,
an active research area
but in the end,
it should come down to minimized energy.
So so that's kind of the central
theme of this.
We want to
we want to minimize free energy.
We did it by perception,
we did it by model learning.
But also the learning of the goals should
be driven by minimizing for energy.
So you should choose the goals
of minimize for energy.
Well, how do you do that?
I don't know.
You tell me, right?
Yeah.
So one more question
that was asked was how
or does this integrate
with graph databases
or with large data sets?
Is this something that Scales
was already integrated to work
with that kind of empirical data or. What
I think it
depends on what you mean
by large data sets. So
so when I hear large data sets,
I usually think about
big data, things like that.
So this toolbox is specifically built
for dynamic modeling, right?
So in the sense that you have
a lot of features in your data,
but it's signal processing.
So data might come in very quickly
and you have a model
of how these data change over time.
So in that sense,
you want to do processing quickly.
So you want a lot, you want velocity,
it's based on processing with velocity
and not processing with volume as for
example, a lot of problems in programing.
Tool boxes are excellent apps like
bytes, auctions and things like that.
Right. Sampling based tool boxes,
Edwards
or great tool boxes.
If you have
volume in terms of data
and you have, for example, an ID model
that you want to that you want to fit.
In our sense, if we talk about large
data, we talk about millions of data
that come in very quickly
and we try to be good at that.
And so that is not yet dead
good at it, to be honest.
But the we access message
passing is going to be the bomb and
that those kind of data sets
there's also a bit of that.
What we do, we really try
to build this toolbox
to build active inference agents.
And the idea that you just put it
in their environment,
they make actions,
they select their own data.
So we don't really try
to build a toolbox
that is really good, just doing machine
learning for a fixed set database,
but rather we try to build models
that, let's say
dynamic models that can adapt
and that can make actions.
And we can then in real time
process streaming data.
And in that sense, over time,
if you wait long enough, yeah, there's
a lot of data streaming through it.
I thought it was
sort of generated by or at least affected
by the agent itself, right?
It don't try to optimize
for some big fixed
databases, rather for just
streaming data in an environment.
It's a really fascinating point
because there's a lot of time dependent
tasks like autonomous driving
where it's like,
OK, here's the 500 terabytes of video
or here's this.
Now give me the best possible score
in a time snapshot.
And it's, it's every single time
with an active inference agent,
we're always including action
of policy selection in the loop.
And so how,
how are we going to deal with that?
But that's why the inspiration from
biological systems becomes so important
it's kind of like when people go,
Oh, well, the brain
must have this processing power.
And then if it were a light bulb
or if it was
this kind of a silicone computer,
it would take up this much energy
ergo, it's efficiency is such and such,
but it's predicated upon
the kind of computers
that we're used to seeing instead of kind
of starting with what already exists.
And then looking for an answer
that rests in that, rather than
how do we make lower power transistors
so that we can fit them into the brain.
So awesome.
Topics.
I think
we're ready for the next presentation
yeah.
Hello, everyone.
Let me also share my screen.
For a second.
That I hope it should work now.
Looks at
so can you see my slides now? Yes.
So OK. So yeah.
Hello again.
My name is Richard Buckeyes
and I want to introduce
you like this new reactive message
pricing based
framework probation in Prince and Juliet
that we call reactive anti.
It's more like our future vision
on solutions for active inference.
Foreign Lab Dojo is like
more like a mature framework.
It works and reactive.
It is our research project for now.
And we are going to start with a question
what is actually reactive
message busting?
And in a in most sense,
this is the same message.
Busing is a formula
but re-implemented in reactive paradigm.
So basically the major issue with
traditional approach as in foreign lab
is that enable in order
to run inference for our model,
we need to create
this show of messages in advance.
So we need to analyze our graph
we need to analyze everything basically.
And we do we need to do it
every time we change our graph structure.
And if graph is big, this graph analysis
time and shuttle creation
may take a lot of extra time
and it might be not a big issue,
but as an engineer,
you may want to test a lot of models
until you're satisfied
with the performance and this extra
delays and schedule creation times,
they may be just a bit of annoying
and reactive message forcing us
allows us to eliminate
this predefined schedule and also
it gives us a lot of other benefits
and possible future research directions
so instead of
having instead of having a fixed shuttle,
we cast our graph to like an event
based system
where everything can react
on its neighbor environment.
And in terms of message passing, nodes
react and incoming messages,
and also it reacts on updated
posterior marginals or our parameter
and the whole model becomes reactive.
We can also react on changes in this
system and basically do whatever we want.
So we may perform some action based on
new updated posterior marginals.
It also in message
passing a natural starting point
is our data or observations,
and the model itself
reacts on changes in our data
or in our priors.
And it also changes
posteriors accordingly
so here I outlined some extra benefits
from the active message
bus implementation.
So first of all, we may outline
biological plausibility
because in nature we probably don't have
any predefined scheduler
for our information flowing on neurons
in our brain, for example,
they are driven by some chemistry,
physics, and in sense
it's like also reactive system.
It constantly adapts
the changes in an environment
and also it reacts only if needed.
And in
terms of message passing based inference,
it may be unnecessary to even react.
And some events, like some messages
if they aren't really important,
if fixed predefined schedule,
you're forced to do all computations
even if you don't really need them.
Another great benefit of draft message
passing is that it
scales very nicely for a very big graph.
So it's more like an answer
for our previous question.
So it supports like hundreds of thousands
of factor nodes,
even millions that are possible.
I will show you an example
in a couple of minutes,
but just to give you a bit of context.
So in this plot, when we model
just some moving
object with known line linear dynamics
and the idea was to estimate and see it
and states given noisy observations.
In this
example, I used common sulfur
with 50,000 observations
and this model contains
roughly about 150,000 factor nodes.
So Bayesian inference
and this kind of a model is impossible
on sampling based inference,
but if reactive message passing,
it takes on about 8 seconds on
just a home MacBook laptop
so we can go the other
and make React system robust
and tolerant to some let's say
failing nodes or missing data
from let's say failed
sensor of a fixed predefined shadow.
If something like this happens,
we need to do everything from scratch.
We need to recreate our model.
We need to again, make a shuttle, ETA,
and it will just take some time
with reactive message fussing.
We may just stop reacting on some missing
data or maybe failing sensor
and we
can just
wait for them to be available again.
It makes it very robust in that sense.
It also gives us an opportunity
to change our graph structure in runtime
and still perform inference
without stopping
so there is a slide
about how we actually do that.
We use Julian's main programing language
in our lap roughly about year
and a half ago we wrote the library
for reactive programing.
Julian.
So it's completely
unrelated to message busing
and just in general framework
for event based systems.
But that allowed us at the later point
to build reactive amp don't jail package
and it implements
free energy minimization
by message Boston.
We also introduced Graph Builder
Gel Package
that is a high level and user friendly
probabilistic model
specification language
that we use in our demos.
Yeah, here I am.
I want to show you an example
just in a second
so you can
you can see my screen, right? Yep.
Maybe one little size larger or two.
I hope it's a little break.
Yeah.
Make it a little larger
than if it looks unexpected.
You can pull back OK.
Here we go.
Yep. Thank you.
So here is our example.
So assume we have some moving object.
It has some hidden space,
and just assume that we know it's
linear dynamics for simplicity
and we don't
we don't have a direct access to its
location, but we have a noisy observation
of this moving object,
and we wish to estimate the true location
of this moving object.
By only observing its noise measurements.
And we may use
a linear multivariate Gaussian state
based model
like equations.
Looks like this.
This are equivalent annotations.
They're the same.
And basically here we say that, OK,
we have a state X timestamp, OK?
And it depends on the
on the previous timestamp step,
some linear operator A
and we also have a transition.
Nice which is a Gaussian
with covariance matrix.
And our observations are
basically modeled
as a Gaussian with covariance matrix.
Q And basically this is our model
and we can simply create the factor
graph out of it.
And as you can see that
our model specification
resembles very closely to the equations
defined above.
So here we have our static
and it's modeled as like a Gaussian
of previous state with some,
let's say known covariance matrices.
And this is how we build our model.
And under this code
it generates factor graph
and we can we can
later on use a reactive and impedance API
to estimate the state of our system.
But here's our example.
It looks a bit of a problem
because I zoomed in a bit
but it's fine, I do it.
And in this example
I perform the common small
for four or 500 points
and I just decompose the trajectory
of this object
into two axis x axis and y axis.
And we can see that common symbol
for predicted
like the real hidden states
of our system correctly,
even though we have a lot of noise
in our system.
So these blue dots,
it's like our noisy observations
and we go, we can go further with this.
So because our system is reactive,
we can, we can estimate
our, our states in real time.
So here is our example.
If we try to run it
I hope it looks smoothly on my computer.
It's actually very smooth,
but I know that maybe
recording
is not that small like screen sharing.
But here in this example,
what we see is that, OK,
we have an infinite data stream
of a moving object that the blue is
the real one and the red is
an estimated one and we can see that.
Now, let me reloaded because it's kind of
and we can see that
react differently, is able
to perform
and Bayesian inference in real time,
and it actually adapts
to changes in the environment
and also changes the posterior
over the current estimated state.
And we can go even further.
You probably noticed this orange line
here just inactive for now,
but we can also incorporate prediction
for this model.
So we can just
we can just extend a little bit our graph
and we can also predict
future state of our system
like this.
So now in this example,
I do Bayesian inference in real time,
and I also predict the future
state of my system like in Orange.
And you can see that prediction
also adapts to the new observations
and it changes basically its future
beliefs over future states
yeah.
Let me stop it
and continue the presentation
so yeah,
I'm going to talk about
like when reactive messages pass things.
Well, actually it's already working
we have a fully working stable
backend and API, for example,
and variation on Bayesian inference.
We also support
expectation propagation, but
that API is not yet
stable, so it might change.
We support
for now only conjugate models
from Exponential Family
we support extra constraints
for operation optimization procedure
such that form
or factorization constraint.
So Rocket a Dodger library
it naturally supports
infinite data streams, for example,
from an internet or from some sensor
and framework
itself is able to handle a missing data
but that API is also not yet stable
here.
Some of our future plans
for this platform.
So we want to extend it to support
non conjugate models as well
basically formula already supports it.
We just need to carefully port
all of the available
existing functionality
from Foreign Lab to react different
and we also want to integrate
with other probabilistic
programing libraries
that exists in Julia Community
Reactive Message Bus
and gives us an opportunity
to try to integrate
parallel inference and react
in different parts of the graph.
Similar tenuously using like multi-core
capabilities of our CPUs
we want to extend
graph detail
to support modular model specification.
For now, it's unfortunately not possible
also,
reactive message busting
naturally gives us an opportunity to run
inference where different
data streams have different
data rates
what that
what I was talking about
in the very beginning about robustness.
But it's also interesting
how far can we push it and maybe
it's possible to automatically
adopt models structure in runtime
based on free energy
but it's like a research project.
We don't really know
if it's possible or not.
For now,
we have some ideas about interactive
visualization for message vessel
based algorithms and free energy
minimization visualization.
And eventually we we are planning
to release this new platform
as a stable version of formula,
possibly to point out.
And that basically is everything
I wanted to show you in my slides
and thank you for your attention.
I will be happy to answer your questions
awesome.
First question was,
is there a paper on this
reactive MP jail or how does that work?
There is, but it's in progress.
So it's not it's not publicly available,
but we are working on that.
So there will be eventually paper
about all of this approach.
I will describe everything, how it works
and how we use it.
So no.
I mean, of course
if anybody writes an email
who wants to get an early copy of
the paper would be happy to share it.
If it stays confidential,
I'd be happy to share.
It's a very interesting development
maybe to the other
authors, like what other
epochs of 40 Lab were there?
How did we get with to this reactive
programing paradigm?
And also it seems like you did
a lot of the foundational work in the lab
on the reactive programing.
Was that just in the Julia implementation
or in the more conceptual grounding.
Yeah,
we did it actually really a lot of work
to support reactive programing in Julia.
Basically
Julia is like the young language
and it has no good capabilities
to run reactive based like systems.
So basically we build it from scratch
yeah.
But we,
we used a lot of like let's say ideas
from other programing languages
that we had experience
with.
I mean,
I know that the academic community
not much lab is fantastic
but for the, for a really
if you want real time
processing of streaming data,
then Julia is a very good
is a better option
because Julia is as almost
has the syntax of MATLAB from a user
but out of
the box, it's almost this fast to see.
And so it's just a better combination for
if you are in engineering
and you actually want to build systems
that are running your time,
you want to make demos
and Julia is better, which is also
Dimitri also makes
use of some really advanced
stuff
and Julia goes for multiple dispatch.
It doesn't matter which one it is,
but it's it's quite events and it's not
available in MATLAB,
but it's extremely useful.
So what we do or do with
it seems to be
if you look at a graph and mass
passing it,
see it seems to be like, oh,
this is actually not so hard to implement
but there's a reason why there are
extremely few toolboxes for the graphs.
So Microsoft has built
one in four dot net and it's, it's great,
but it's not really a real time tool box.
And so as far as we know are
there's not much competition
at the moment for us not.
But our tool box is very advanced yet.
But I don't see a lot of people
working on this.
I see a lot of people
working on their most kind of sampling,
but not kind of something.
A lot of work for the sizes of systems
and the real time data streams
that we want to do with active inference.
Right?
We are
working in systems where we want
to make actions and influence our data.
So this is a real time system and
and so we have to go to
actually scale up.
We have to go to built a really high
quality professional tool box
that automates message passing.
I hope
this will be one of those two boxes and
hopefully they're also the other tool.
But yeah, that's why we're doing this.
Very interesting answer.
How has the dialog between
the math and programing
and computer science side and the active
inference side been like,
what has each side kind of contributed?
Because it sounds like some of those
real time insights of active inference
are kind of propagating
back to the design of algorithms,
and then we see both directions.
So how has that played out
maybe for any of each for each of you.
I can also answer
maybe this question
from my point of view.
I mostly like doing programing,
but I still learn something new
every time
because we like in this constant dialog
with math guys
and our let's say,
and I learn something new every day.
And of course it reflects like our design
choices for our software as well.
So it's kind of
but sometimes it's, it's very hard
to fit this high level
of my symmetrical ideas
to the actual implementation.
And also it's very hard
to make it efficient.
So yeah, we are not
we're not done with this.
I mean, the tool box is available anybody
and all the nice toy examples, the basic
thermostat, the Tic-Tac-Toe,
and it all looks very smooth.
The tower.
Our hope
is that with reactive masses passing,
we can actually get past the scaling
is up to serious applications.
And that that's what I mean.
We're an engineering group.
We want to build systems
that really do something useful.
I also work for a hearing aid company,
so I want to build the real time
audio processing algorithms
and others may want to
use this for robotics. So
yeah, but that's not going to work in
real time
until it's not going to work. It's
yeah, I mean, all the more
the kind of stuff.
And so
this is our effort
and it's quite
it's takes a long time because it's
very multidisciplinary efforts, right?
We have in my group,
we have a mathematicians and
neuroscience kids and computer scientists
because it's difficult.
There's a lot of different expertizes
that that you need to build your toolbox
for active inference
I think because it's so difficult,
there is a lot of like
a cross first position between
the active inference community
and the engineering that we do
the community is mostly interested
in explaining biological systems.
So I do the same energy
principle active inference
as is multiple biology.
And I think it's very interesting
because, well, nature has a certain way
of doing things efficiently.
And if this is a model for that
then it's also a good idea
to take that to engineering.
And that's kind of where we come in.
So we kind of take the ideas
that are available
in the X Inference community
and where they explain brains
and think about brains and saying, Hey,
how can we take these ideas
and use them
to build an engineering system
and I think that's kind of the main,
you know,
the main interaction between it.
And hopefully then we build tools that
the community
can also use that in their research.
Eventually
what that made me think about
was it's really
a reframing of some of the main
challenges, like seeing signal processing
as a real time event or seeing the causal
relationships between action
and future data, all these kinds
of reframing of the problem.
It's not like the active inference
algorithms take
massive matrix calculations to do per se.
They can be very simple or not,
but it's actually that reframing
and the embedding of action
within every step
that then ends up solving the scaling,
some of the scaling,
some challenges, some of the resilience
challenges, because like resilience
of a transportation network in a city,
they would do sampling
or they would take something
that's an unfolding dynamic process
and then try to roll out
a million iterations of it statically.
So it's again, it's
not that the calculations
inside of the loop
have to be challenging.
It's just a reframing of prioritizing.
Action ended up
going down these roads of scaling
and real time capacity.
Yeah, I like that.
The thought of perhaps
I can say something about this
in the context of what I work on
because I work on designing basically I'm
a hearing engineer, I work on
and if you ask a hearing
engineer or signal processing engineer,
so what is your task?
Well, our task is to build
the best hearing out of it.
And so
then what happens is that in a hearing,
a client goes to the store
and buys a hearing aid
and usually it's very happy and goes out.
And then two weeks later it sits
in a restaurant and cannot understand
a conversation partner
because there's noise
and this wasn't expected
and there's nothing she can do
because you can't ask a client,
a hearing aid clients
to tell you fiddle
with hearing it parameters.
So if this happens a few times,
then she throws and she puts her hearing
aid in the drawer
and this is about ten to 20% of hearing
it end up in a drawer.
They're very expensive and
and 20% ends up not being useful.
Really sad statistic.
So right here you can,
you can turn around and say, OK,
what is the real hearing
aid design problem?
The real hearing aid design problem is
send somebody out with any hearing it.
But what do you do
when she's unhappy in the field,
as in the restaurant?
And what we want to build is an agent
that will then.
So she just slaps her wrist,
which I'm happy.
And now this agent
needs to make an action
and give her a new parameter, set things
that are the most interesting for her
and in the best compromise
between information
seeking and goal driven goals,
we can be making her happy.
So hearing a design from
my viewpoint now is just build an agent
that will make actions, make hearing it
proposals when she's unhappy,
and if she
isn't happy and then it makes proposal
says, no, that's good.
Well, the agent gives another proposal
and that is OK, that's better.
And then we move on.
And maybe a week later, the same event
and this goes on continually.
But there is at least
a procedure to keep moving on,
to keep improving over time.
Right.
So that's the real thing of design
is the is
then the the action in the field in situ,
which is very different from what's
currently happening, which is a hearing
aid engineer sitting at the desk
with MATLAB, not in the environment.
So that's it's a paradigm shift
and at if insurance agents
can maybe make that happen
and it could be really I think
great a pivoting point for something
like signal processing design
is not something that you think about
when you're in there scientist
but this could really mean
something big for engineering
and not just for signal processing
but also in different
engineering disciplines.
And so that's why I think over time
you'll see more and more people
coming from different fields
getting an interest in this
active of and the fancy principle
even in non
the not neuroscientists right
but engineers and yeah yeah.
Cool we hope so.
And that really reminds me
of the pragmatic turn,
which is it's a little bit
like a horseshoe theory
with the engineers and the philosophers
often talking about pragmatism
in different ways,
different communities, different tools.
And now there's a way to kind of
close that gap, or at least map across it
where we can embed
some of those insights about
really an
activism, the role of design, science,
anticipatory design, science with
Take It or leave it philosophy,
or there's the toolkit to develop.
Maybe it's interesting
five years after working with the toolkit
or maybe five years of philosophy, and
then you're curious about the toolkit.
So one question was
how do these graphs account
for temporally deep models
how are those specified or what
make what is different about the graph?
Because it's just calculating
the next action to take in the examples
that you provided.
Maybe you can show your graph again,
how the future is presented,
how you attempt to effective to that.
For example, this kind of
so if you ask if you have a graph
like share screen is
if you have a graph like this,
then how do you add temporal sequence?
For example,
that's this just about adding layers.
So what is shown here is one layer
and is layer x.
It acts at a certain block time
and no observations come in discretely
but you might have layer above this
that is somehow
connected to this layer below
that acts at a higher temporal timescale.
So it evolves slower,
but it regulates or influences
the parameters of,
for example, a transition model here
or an observation model here.
So you get a time
varying observation model
that is influenced by a slower
evolving layer.
On top of that, you can get
an even slower resolving later, right?
And that's just the way
you can build hierarchies
when actually there's
also pages
students in our group, Ismael's seniors,
who has done some very interesting
work on that, and he has investigated
how you make hierarchical
all coercion filters.
So hierarchical
Goshen systems, where you have one
top player influencing the variance
of the transition
model of the layer below.
And you can see that
you can get lot models,
very natural signals with that.
So so in nature, as you have,
you have signals that are time varying
the statistics
there, they're time varying,
and the statistics of those models
are times varying.
So a hierarchical model in that sense
can be very useful for that.
And of course this is of course
also how our brains are structured.
So again,
you have this inspiration from nature
on how to structure the models
that we try to build
so it's photographs
and at least in theory,
this should be pretty easy
because you can just connect them,
you can connect layer on top of this
and, and see how it behaves
and then eventually
the complexity of your model
will become very high
and you'll get penalized for it
automatically.
So there will be a cutoff point
given your data and that will be
the optimal amount of layers
that you need in order to explain away
all variance
that you observe, which is
so so that's kind of how we think about,
yeah, temporal thickness
and time dependance
and dynamical models like this.
Then can I share my screen also?
Yep, sure.
Yeah.
See, because this.
Awesome. Yeah.
So this is a graph from a paper
a few years back
from two years, it's called I think
deep temporal models.
You should check the graphs or something.
And here you see a three layer system.
I mean, don't bother about the details.
Now but here you see that
the top layer just basically has one
bottom section, one time step.
And in that time step on the top layer,
you have two observations or two steps
at the middle layer.
I need
not sure if you can see my.
We see it. We said. OK.
And then again, for the third layer,
whenever
the middle of tips takes one step
we have two steps here.
So so there is sort of a fine grained
granularity of each layer, right?
And so we can build hierarchical
models really.
And so we're doing that
also in a view to also view you.
You look at some of the papers
on our website, you'll find
a lot of pages on the hierarchical
garrison filter from Chris Martin.
So if implemented, that in and also
I mean, you can also do attractive,
interesting things like
the look of like this.
So Thomas Power has also graphs
like this in some of these papers.
Very interesting.
And we see a lot of the same variables
like GDP, like we can.
It's kind of a different representation
of active inference so yeah,
this is kind of also going back
I think to the earlier Frontiers paper.
What are some of the big equivalencies
or kind of like airtight mappings
from an to form factor
graphs because there's probably
some broad areas of application
that could almost be hot swapped
for this underlying it perhaps.
So what are the equivalencies with just
Bayesian graphs in general versus
factor
graphs versus other topics at that level?
I think for style
facts, graphs
or a bipartite graph revision network,
they are really different
they can be used as
they're just a representation
of a sexualized model.
And the way you represent that
can have
an impact
about how you think about those models.
So for example,
if you choose a photo style photograph,
representation is very suited
for signal processing because you kind of
can see these messages, the signals
that flow over your graphs.
So for us as engineers,
this is a very intuitive representation
Invasion Networks is a bit more.
The mode of representation
itself is more compact in that sense
that you only have variable nodes
and you see how they relate.
So it gives you
a good idea of model structure.
So it can be very nice to
have a quick overview of model like that.
And then you have for example,
a bipartite graph which also shows
a relation between variables as an additional kind of vector nodes in between
and it
gives you a bit more
granularity on how these are connected
and gives you room to talk about, well,
what is the relationship
between these variables
and so in the end, they're equivalent
you can take one model
and represented in three different
ways, maybe even more
but I think it does impact just the way
how you think
or how you think about these models.
So then that usually comes up
in writing a paper
and then you have to think, Okay,
what is actually the best representation
for my idea?
Sometimes it's about budget growth,
sometimes it's vision
afterwards, sometimes it's
so I still think to graphs,
it just depends on your story.
And hopefully a positive question.
I do find though, I mean, you may
experience when we think about systems
and a whole set of equations,
if you read that in a paper
or if you write it down,
it gives
more insight, which to me it gives
more insight if I draw the graph and
an X must be an exact correspondence
between the
the graph and the equations.
And very often if you draw the graph
and then you write down the equations,
there is not an extensive correspondence.
So you learn from it.
You basically, you know,
there must be x x correspondence
and basically you often find out
you have an error in your equations
or in you graph.
I think
like the end goal and goal
is to make toolbox a toolbox for,
let's say for the community to design
their own active inference agents
and I envision
there is something like Simulink.
I'm not sure about my lab few, I'm
not sure if people are familiar
with that,
but these are graphical models.
You want to actually also define them
graphically.
If you want to have a palette it notes
and just draw your graph and say,
This is my model and now go run.
You don't want to worry
about the of influences.
I don't have the root defenses,
but it should be done by the designers.
Of the toolbox.
But you should just be thinking
about your graphical structure.
That's the
and disrupt and connect it
with your mouse
to your microphone of the computer
or to your camera and maybe to
you nowadays.
Also connectors
in the tool box for robots.
And then it should just go right.
That's what I read because of graphs.
So a lot of
that's how you want to design anything.
You just want to draw the brain
and the generative model of the brain
and just let it go.
And don't worry
about how inference takes place.
What what you just said there
about viewing the equation
and then maybe going from the pen
and paper to the programing language
to the graphical representation
and then kind of cross-checking.
It's like when you reverse
translate languages and when you lock in
where two words map back to each other,
you know, you've made a map.
But if you're on this infinite loop,
you're you're lost in the word space.
So when you move across sectors like that
or across modalities,
whether analytical,
the simulations on the computer
and then the graphical,
it kind of embeds action
in what otherwise
might be seen as a knowledge
product, a product of inference,
and then a final action.
And that's a similar fallacy to
train the dynamic process in a snapshot
and then expect that it's
going to work in real time.
So it's like embedding this real time
flow in the production of knowledge.
Yes. Yes. You are.
Important. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean,
learning act definitions
while we are trying to design this stuff.
That's true. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
11 general question
was just about factorization.
So the factorization, the way we go about
it is starting with our intuition
and looking for residuals or
how of all the ways to factor as a model,
do we find one
that works
yeah.
There's two kinds of factorization.
There's a factorization
in, let's say, that generative model.
That's the graph that we draw
and so I mean, let's say most people
or the most common models are these.
I mean, this is these,
these Markov models,
right, where you
you kind of retain a current state.
And it summarizes
everything that happens in the past
and you use the current state
to basically to summarize the past.
And then that's all the information
that so
you don't need to remember the passages,
remember your state.
And with that,
you make a new observation.
You combine
the information, make a new state
and so forth, so hidden Markov models
from the piece.
All these models
have that same structure, these pieces,
this microstructure so that sort of
generative model of of Islamic systems.
Then there is a second question.
If we know the inference
and then there's often
what we call the mean field assumption
for the variation of posterior.
But there are also variants
on that structure mean fields.
So you can you can
fill this side if you want
your posterior to be even more structure
let's say even more effects arise
and the generative model.
But in the end, yeah, it's a
it's a proposal
you just run it
and if you have another proposal,
you just run it.
And the one that has the lowest strategy
wins.
That's that's it.
The challenge is to automate
that process, though,
from the power
structure to the better structure
just by forgetting to
minimization, just by message
passing in real time without
stopping the whole process,
doing an analysis right.
You should just get boring, right?
It should just just
structure adaptation should be like state
estimation just keeps moving over time.
There's no resetting.
Maybe there's a bit of a thing like
the dreaming stage, right?
But if predictable time moves on
and that's the challenge
and we don't know
that in our effectiveness, but we we
I mean,
we have one student
who's currently looking into that.
Yeah.
Like as an engineer, I think the question
is, well, what do you start out with?
What is what
will be your initial model proposal?
So if you talk about factorization
of your generative model, you think so
every sector then
kind of represents a prior distribution
or conditional distribution.
That's
how you kind of build up your model.
Where do you start
it starts with how you believe
the world generates observations.
So in a sense, you think about
what is the causal structure
of environment, and you might have
some idea about how physics works
or how
states transition in in your environment,
or at least
how you believe this transition.
And that's kind of where you start
and you think, OK, well,
maybe let's try a very course notice -1.
For example, in my talk,
let's try that here
because I don't really know
what I want to put there,
but I have to put something.
Let's try something
and see how that works.
It kind of models,
how I believe the world works
and that's that's how you start out.
And then you start thinking, Well,
I actually know a bit more about it.
I'm not satisfied
with how this model proposed,
how this model works,
and I can change this.
Mine's one, for example,
with with something as big, more complex
because I know
the physics. I know how these
temperature degrades with
so a distance, for example,
and I can build that in.
And so that's
how you go to a second proposal.
And it's always inspired by
how you believe
because the structure of the world is
is yeah. Is how that works.
So in that sense, kind of see rebuilding,
you're building a theory
or an explanation of your environment
and or maybe if you're really,
really good,
if you have an excellent model,
then you can find something that
kind of improves upon state of the art
because you can always improve.
Just find something that gives you
a level of free energy
or better performance in a sense.
And you can keep tweaking and tweaking
these models and these transitions
and, and things like that. Then
yeah.
Free energy
minimization has been described
or just as a way to rank
the different models and as an imperative
on these multiple different fronts.
How do we know that free energy
minimization is making the policy
that is going to be like resilient?
Is there a way where, similar
to local optimization, getting trapped
somewhere in a bigger optimization space,
there might be some avenue
of free energy minimization
that makes the system just like break
down, like we'll get there faster,
let's just accelerate.
And then there's some kind of one time
failure of the system I'm just wondering,
how can one metric that's a number,
you know, and can be sorted, how can it
evaluate such radically
different chess strategies or
driving approaches.
So the end is just probability.
Theory and probability
is also just a number, right?
And if energy
kind of it approximates your evidence,
which is the probability
according to your model
of observing the data.
So if you make a model
that gives you the best evidence,
then it's good explanation for for your
for your data.
So in the end, it's just
you try to do approximate
probability theory
and if the energy is
then bound upon your evidence
and it also takes into account
and is posterior divergence term,
which kind of says the price that you pay
for approximating Bayesian inference.
So it has two parts to it.
It has the model evidence part
and it has the posterior divergence part
and both play a role.
One says, OK,
this is the quality of my solution.
It's how well
your model explains the data
that you observe you can get
and you can get a number for that.
The surprise
or the negative log model evidence
and you have the other part
of the versions divergences says, well,
this is the price and information that
you pay for making this approximation.
You can also put a number on that.
It's just a scale of urgency to evaluate
and then you add those two
and you get a number
so yeah, so
the question is how can one number
kind of represent
everything in terms of quality?
Well,
you might care about different things
then how well your model predicts
or evaluates the observations right?
And then if you care about other things
then, then
yeah.
And then you might
use different number. But
in our in our sense, in our, in our
in our work, yeah, we kind of
everyone's
have this Bayesian measure of quality.
No, I don't know
that really answer your question,
but it's still a good question.
That's
this kind of is, is free energy
or the number that you get?
Is that enough?
Right.
That's just kind of what's behind this.
And probability theory says yes,
but if you apply in effect
is that you care about
maybe other things.
You care about how many people survive
or how many, you know,
how many how many mistakes you
your cash from from something.
And if you care about that, well,
then you should
use that as a performance metric,
I think.
Right. I mean, it's
the differentiate, of course,
has has many decompositions, right?
In actual complexity minus security
and and surprise minus
minus the key, all the virtues.
But I'm not sure if I interpret
the question correctly,
but if you say like, how do you know that
it does well in practice in the field?
Well, you don't, right?
The look,
the only thing you can say is that,
I mean, what the system does,
it will look for the configuration
that minimizes free energy.
But you don't know what you don't know.
You don't know if there is another model
that will do better if we haven't
simulated this model that we don't know.
And the only learning opportunities
there are
is to is to generate errors.
So the only way to really improve
the model is to actually hit, indeed,
let's say, situations
where it's not working
and then you need to adapt
your parameters
and and even more over time,
you adapt your structure.
So yeah, it's I mean, building
a good system is a process,
right?
It's not
a matter of just
you have to be extremely lucky
if you just build a system
and it's completely works right
it's this this we or most active
interest
describes is a process towards better
systems.
But not it doesn't describe a system
that doesn't make
mistakes, in fact,
that needs the mistakes to learn.
And it describes the process
awesome points.
It's operational insight
that if you're getting 100% of the test
like something is at the very best
or less than informative,
at the very worst
you're you're way down the wrong path.
And, and then it reminds me
of like a grocery store is it
let were ranking the different objects
according to one measure no not really.
It's like balancing strategies
for finding preference
and that's where all of these assumptions
like the factorization
in the mean field and it's not guaranteed
to give you the best object every time.
And there's still the stochastic city
of the real world and the ability
of the grocery store to change
like it's not the end of the story.
It's actually just a practice
and a process
that has some of the features of reactive
graphs and biological systems.
That's right.
Yeah.
If any of you have any final comments,
this was just really
one of the coolest times
to learn about this, but
you're always welcome back to join
any time as a participant or to present.
And if you have any final comments,
you can note them.
Well, it was a real pleasure to be here.
And if we have new stuff,
we would love to come back.
I think it's such a fantastic show
here or show.
It's a forum or whatever
it's properly called,
but I really enjoyed it
and we really enjoyed being part of it.
And thanks so much for the discussion.
Some some folks are something as well.
This is really cool.
Especially for the opportunity
to present this.
Great. OK, till next.
Time. Yeah. Bye.
Bill, I buy, buy, buy, buy, buy,
buy, buy, buy, buy, buy, buy,
buy, buy, buy, buy, buy, buy.
But I buy.
Like, I bet I.